and it's not just keeve that's being
besieged by russian forces all across
southern ukraine putin's troops are
closing in on the nation's major cities
curson with a population of 300 000
people has become the first ukrainian
city to fall into russia's hands their
mayor is claiming hundreds of brave
residents have been killed with many of
their bodies unrecognizable
because of putin's barbaric weapons
and unfortunately kersanne is not alone
about 250 miles east the critical port
city of maripo has been engulfed by
russian forces invading troops have the
city surrounded by both land and
and are raining explosives down on the
innocent people trapped inside
the city's deputy mayor detailed the
horrors
their style of war is to make
humanitarian increases we have
continuous shelling for
uh 26 hours 26 hours they are destroying
our city
so from all the weapons from artillery
from airplane bombing from tactical
rockets from multiple launch rocket
system so situation is very bad if
russia is able to capture maripole
they're going to connect crimea directly
to their forces in russia proper and the
breakaway east
this land bridge
allows him to move troops and weapons
across the entire southern half of the
country without interference
this isolates and traps ukrainian forces
and chokes off ukrainian supply lines
russia's immediate goal is to continue
their march to the west with their eyes
set on two additional port cities
michaelave and odessa odessa being the
crown jewel the commercial capital and
key port
if they fall ukraine will be completely
cut off from supplies and support coming
up from the black sea
land locking ukraine's forces
while odessa could also be used as the
launching point of any invasion of
ukraine's neighbor moldova which
directly borders a nato member romania
where american forces are stationed
right now
the heroic people of ukraine refuse to
give in to russia's aggression
but this is going to be a long and drawn
out battle
russia has no plans to stop this
ferocious assault any time soon and is
spewing propaganda brainwashing its own
people
i will never
forgo my conviction that the russians
and
ukrainians are a single people even
though the citizens of ukraine
are intimidated and many of them are
misguided
with a nationalist propaganda we are
fighting with nazis the nationalist
detachments which include foreign
fighters including from the middle east
is to use peaceful citizens as a human
shield
while russia commits war crimes putin
blames ukraine
he also keeps repeating that ukraine is
under nazi control
russia's foreign minister was challenged
by abc over this listen
we believe that president zielenski
the first jewish president of ukraine
whose families were killed in the
holocaust is a nazi
i think that the nazis in neo-nazis
manipulate him otherwise it is hard to
recount exhibited stewards for how
president zielenski can reside in a
society of a society where neo or nazis
miss rife
obviously that's preposterous
on the sidelines of this real war
there's an information war going on and
it's wild depending on what country you
live in some people have no idea what to
believe
sources are now even telling fox news
that russia's federal security service
has drafted plans to conduct public
executions in ukrainian cities once
they've been captured
putin's unpredictable and capable of
anything at this point he's threatened
nuclear war he staged coups bombs
civilians poisoned political enemies
he's conspiring with china and has
launched multiple and vicious ground
invasions
this is what the people of ukraine are
up against
putin's digging in for the long haul
here
even insisting his invasion is going
according to plan
french president spoke with
vlad putin today by phone and
the russian leader told macron it's
going to get a lot worse from here and
that he's going to take the entire
country of ukraine
so what's next hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else